Hi.
On this week's grimmer spotlight,
we're going to talk about the difference between two commonly misused verbs lay
and why.
Before we get into the details of lay and lie,
let's do a quick review of verb transitivity.
Generally speaking,
birds are divided into two categories.
Transitive,
intransitive,
all verbs express an action of some kind,
but only transitive verbs transfer that action to a direct object and when
trends and adverbs are used without a direct object,
they sound incomplete.
For example,
by as a transitive verb,
it transfers its action to an object.
When used in a sentence,
the doctor bought a new car.
In this sentence,
the doctor is the subject,
she is performing the action of buying and that action is transferred to a
direct object.
In this case,
the car,
the Berg,
Bob takes the direct object and thus is a transitive verb.
Also,
you can tell that by is a transitive verb.
By removing the direct object from the sentence and seeing how it sounds,
the doctor Bhat,
it sounds incomplete.
Those we know that by is a transitive verb and needs a direct object in order to
be complete.
Intransitive verbs on the other hand,
do not require a direct object in order to complete their sentence.
For example,
laugh is an intransitive burb I laughed heartedly.
I am the subject of the sentence.
Laughs is the verb,
but there is no direct object.
I cannot say I laughed the joke but wait,
you might be saying,
I can say I laughed at the joke.
Wouldn't add the joke be the direct object in this case.
No it isn't.
Why?
Because at the joke is really just a propositional phrase.
Where at is the preposition and joke is the object of the preposition.
In this case you can think of the propositional phrase at the joke as a phrase
that gives you more information about the circumstances at the laughing or how
the lapping was carried out,
but do not confuse it with the direct object.
But what does all this have to do with lay and lie lady as a transitive verb,
which means it requires a direct object in order to complete it.
Since I lay the pencil on the table,
I lay the cat in her cat hammock.
Lie is an intransitive verb,
which means it doesn't require a direct object in order to complete its,
since I need to go lie down.
So what's the big confusion?
The main confusion comes when you get out of the present tense.
The past tense of lie is in fact lay.
Yeah.
So today I need to lie down,
but yesterday I lay in bed all day and in case you need to do a compound tense,
the past partless love beloved lie is lane.
So I had laid in bed for just two hours before the picker boy came and the
progressive form is lying.
So I been lying here all day.
The past tense of lay on the other hand is laid.
So today I lay the pencil on the table,
but yesterday I laid the pencil on the table.
The past participle of lay is also laid.
So I had just laid the pencil on the table when you walked in.
The progressive form is lane.
So I haven't been laying pencils on this table all day.
So all you about to remember is lay laid,
laid.
His transitive and lie lay lane is intransitive.
Also,
it might help if you just sit there repeating them for awhile until next time.
Lay laid,
laid lie lane,
Lane Lane,
laid laid lie lane,
lane lay,
lay,
lay lie lane lane lay led,
led lie lay lane.